in terms of filmmakers seeking
distribution deals what should they be
aware of all of your films out
distribution yeah I've been fortunate
enough to get all my previous films
distributed in some form or another and
I think part of the key has been
festivals to be honest in certain
festivals I think planning the right
festival strategy is very key we for my
first two films I was sure to submit the
film to certain like market festivals
that was what's that one in New York
called independent film week it used to
be called ifp market I think it's a week
long kind of like a festival screenings
and they have work in progress screens
as well and it's very well attended by
by press by distributors as well and
that's a great way to get face-to-face
time with actual distributors like I met
Greg REM from HBO documentaries there
twice and got to know him through that
process and so that I think those market
festivals is very key and when you go to
festivals you can you can't forget about
the marketing aspect like people have to
know that you're there and you have to
get creative you know you do the common
things like the post guards and the
posters but you also have to think
creatively beyond that like what kinds
of publicity stunts can you pull or you
know just what kind of unique things can
you do to get the press to write about
it that kind of thing I remember when we
premiered its silver docks with one of
my previous phones it didn't end up
working out because of the rain and
whatnot but we wanted a chalk artist to
do this huge like portrait of one of our
characters like on the sidewalk right
outside the theater and you know things
like that you gotta just kind of have to
think creatively I remember for my first
film flight from death we did a little
DVD like premiere party and we hired an
actor to dress up in a huge like grim
reaper outfit and just kind of walk
around the party and just kind of roam
not talk to anybody but just stand next
to people and you know so yeah try and
think as creatively as possible I think
the bottom line is though it's a ton of
work just trying to get the word out
about your phone
and like i said this festival is
credible festivals that are attended by
distributors is is pretty key what are
some red flags that so much to be aware
of the distribution deal um red flags
with distribution deals you know it
depends on what kind of distribution
deal we're talking about I guess you
know the Commission rate is something
you should always be very conscious of
you know if it's a small I've dealt with
small foreign sales agencies that I
wanted to charge forty percent of
revenue which is astronomical you know
it should be more in the range of twenty
to twenty-five percent and so yeah
definitely making sure that's kind of
aligned with industry standards is very
important you know the credibility of
the company itself is very big with my
first film I didn't know any better and
we took basically one of the first deals
that came along and ended up being
almost like almost mcnear scam artists
you know like they were legitimate
company and they were distributing films
and they got her store film on the store
shelves but I mean it was a disaster
behind the scenes like from accounting
to marketing and it was just it was
awful I mean I don't even think we got
our painting money from that deal ever
and it was a struggle just to kind of
get out of the contract and so
definitely doing a research on who these
companies are it is very very important
when someone offers you a deal calling
other filmmakers that have signed with
them previously is a no-brainer you got
to do that have conversations with them
about you know the pros and cons of
their dealings with that company that
kind of thing just do your research yeah
you